you know how we had a celebrity run for
office Ronald Reagan hey you will not
believe Back to the Future you know the
actor Ronald Reagan yeah he's going to
be the president United States what are
you talking about right so celebrity
becomes a uh uh now he was a governor
two terms you know he was a president of
uh you know but at the same time he
became a president you know Trump became
a president do you see anybody that's a
celebrity type name to become a
president like a rock or any of those
guys
well as we have now learned one of the
greatest single qualifications is to be
well known so until Trump all of your
Presidents had either been a governor a
U.S senator or a general for some you've
had a business person but not just any
business person a business person who
who seriously fed and burnished their
Public Image uh you know for for for 40
years so yeah somebody could emerge uh
from uh from the World of Sports or from
entertainment but I do think Reagan's
different Reagan was a successful
two-year two-term Governor the largest
state in the country so he didn't just
jump from from Death Valley days to the
White House I think that I think people
are looking for that now the difference
is in a business person whether it's
Ross Perot whether it's Donald Trump if
you build a billion dollar company then
people think you're qualified to run the
federal government
yeah somebody just did a Super Chat
saying uh Republicans are so soft they
let the November 2020 uh contest slide
and did absolutely nothing about it was
the point of Second Amendment uh if
you're too scared to execute don't
celebrate Fourth of July Constitution
was written for this
etc etc this is Ivan whoever it is I
can't say the last uh part of the name
anyways I mean listen it's a it I think
it's a very unpredictable time we have
no idea what's going to happen but I
think for in in regards to politics
eyeball sports like if it was a sport I
think this is a phenomenal season can't
wait the next 22 months I think is going
to be phenomenal I think it's going to
be like a uh what we saw with the World
Cup and how much you know intensity
there was in it's going to be similar to
that so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you
[Music]